Facebook bars louis farrakhan Alex Jones
in Milo Annapolis Democrats continue to
smear Attorney General William Bar and
we checked the mailbag I'm Ben Shapiro
this is the Ben Shapiro show and a lot
to get to today we'll jump into all of
it momentarily but first hiring is
challenging there is one place you can
go where hiring is simple fast and smart
it's a place where growing businesses
connect to qualified candidates that
place is zip recruiter comm slash daily
wire zip recruiter sends your job to
over 100 of the web's leading job boards
but they don't stop there with their
powerful matching technology zip
recruiter scans thousands of resumes to
find people with the right experience
and then invites them to apply to your
job those applications come in zip
recruiter analyzes each one and
spotlights the top candidates so you
never miss a great match zip recur is so
effective that four out of five
employers who post on zip recruiter to
get a quality candidate through the site
within the very first day
and right now my listeners can try zip
recruiter for free at this exclusive web
address zip recruiter comm slash daily
wire that's Dai ly w ir e that is zip
recruit comm slash daily wires zip
recruiter comm slash at daily where we
use zip recruiter right here at the
daily wire offices whenever we are
looking to upgrade our hires and it is a
fantastic way for you to save time and
money in the hiring process go to zip
recruiter comm slash daily wire and try
it out for free zip recruiter the
smartest way to hire go check it out
right now alrighty so the big story of
the day to begin is the situation with
regard to the United States economy
we'll get to the censorship on face book
in just one second but the Senate the
the US economy created 263 thousand jobs
in April unemployment has now fallen to
its lowest rate since 1969 since 1969 so
the economy continues to boom for all
the talk about President Trump and his
volatility in President Trump and
President Trump and president the fact
is president Trump's policies have made
businesses feel comfortable his
regulatory policies have made them feel
as though they are not going to be
targeted the fact that Republicans still
control the Senate provides a check on
democratic excesses so businesses are
looking at all of this and they are
saying okay well for the foreseeable
future
let's keep pumping money into the system
foreseeable let's hire up is a good time
for the economy let's make this thing
happen the economy generated a
stronger-than-expected 200
63 thousand new jobs in April helping to
drive down the unemployment rate to a 49
year low of 3.6 percent the increase in
new jobs easily topped the 2200 17,000
market watch forecast the jobless rate
slid from 3.8 percent in March to hit
the lowest level since December of 1969
economists consider anything below a 4
percent unemployment rate in the United
States to effectively be full employment
the average wage paid to American
workers rose 6 cents or 0.2 percent to
$27 77 cents an hour now I want to again
emphasize that wage $27.77 an hour we
keep hearing from the left that a $15
minimum wage is necessary the average
wage in the United States is more than
$12 more than that the number of people
who are surviving on minimum wage is
extraordinarily low overall the 12 month
out rate of hourly wage gains was
unchanged at 3.2 percent
hoursworked each week each week fell
point one hour in April to 31 are being
deeply overworked if people are working
less than 35 hours a week on average it
is hard to make the case that they are
being desperately overworked less than
35 hours a week on average and wages are
increasing means that people aren't
being worked harder for Less pay it
means they are making more pay for
working fewer hours 35 hours a week is 7
hours a day hey some simple math will
tell you this this does not mean that
people are slaving away you know in a in
a wage slave economy the way the
Democrats seem to be suggesting the
government revised the increase in new
jobs in March to 189,000 from
preliminary 196,000 February's gain was
raised from 56 it was raised to 56,000
from 33,000 which means that the past
months have also seen higher increases
in jobs than normal the economy is still
going great guns president Trump's
economy he doesn't get full credit for
the economy because no president does
Obama didn't but he does get credit for
not quashing the economy President Obama
got blame for the slowest recovery in
American history and the economy
continues to boom so this is very good
news for president Trump as I have said
if the economy continues to be good and
if President Trump keeps his mouth shut
then he will have a significant shot of
being able to win a general election
re-election bid if you read the polls
right now it's fascinating if you look
at the polls right now what you are see
is that the various Democrats running
against President Trump are not running
in the mid-50s you would expect given
president Trump's approval rating that
all of these polls would have Trump at
42% the same as his approval rating but
his approval rating does not match up
with the number of people who say they
will vote for him his approval rating
hangs around in the low 40s the number
of people who say that they will vote
for him is always hanging about 45 to 47
percent in fact the only candidate in
this new CNN poll this is amazing this
new CNN poll the only candidate who
drives who drives Trump down to his
approval rating in terms of his public
support for voting is bade oh really
may this new poll from CNN has bado at
52 and trump at 42 it's pretty hilarious
actually so it has but it has Bernie at
50 and Trump at 44 which I think would
not be the final result of that election
cycle it has Biden at 51 and Trump at 45
which is the reason that Biden right now
is doing so well in the primaries
because Democrats are effectively
suggesting that he is the most electable
candidate Pete Budaj edge only at 47
percent to Trump's 44% Kamala Harris at
49% to Trump's 45% so they're not
winning a majority against the guys
unpopular as president Trump Elizabeth
Warren loses to trump in this poll so
Trump 48 Elizabeth Warren 47 naturally
this means probably that Democrats will
probably nominate Elizabeth Warren I
think that's the way this works okay so
that's the latest on the political race
now the real big news this morning is
not even the economy all that's huge
news
the real big news this morning is that
Facebook has now banned a bevy of what
the media termed far-right extremists
there's only one problem some of the
people who are termed far-right
extremists are not in fact of the right
okay so they labeled Louis Farrakhan a
far-right leader
the New York Times talked about talked
about what happened here and then we'll
gets the media coverage of the actual
issue so the New York Times originally
said that far-right extremists were
being banned and they used that
description for Louis Farrakhan the
leader of the Nation of Islam and a
virulent anti-semite who's been pictured
with virtually everybody in prominent
circles on the left an article for the
Atlantic was originally titled Instagram
and Facebook banned far-right extremists
the New York Times washing
in post political in the Atlantic all
describe blues Farrakhan is a far-right
extremist now the reason that this
matters I will get to in just one second
so here is the actual story according to
the New York Times
after years of wavering about how to
handle the extreme voices populating its
platform Facebook on Thursday evicted
seven of its most controversial users
many of whom are conservatives
immediately in flaming the debate about
the power and accountability of large
technology companies now I think it is
worthwhile noting here that the New York
Times description is funny as soon as
they start describing people who are
fringe like Alex Jones they start
calling them conservatives that's
because for the press there is no
difference
from between conservatives and quote
far-right extremists and according to
the Economist I was alright and then
when they corrected it I was a radical
conservative there is no difference for
the media between a normal mainstream
conservative and Alex Jones they just
don't see any distinction there and not
only that they also see if somebody is
extreme that person must be far-right
that I've never seen any of these
newspapers describe anybody as far as I
can recall as a far left extremist right
Bernie Sanders is an open socialist who
used to defend the Soviet Union and talk
about the glories of bread lines and he
is the secondary contender in the
Democratic primaries right now the press
conflate conservatism with all right and
then they conflate not being a wild
leftist with with being a conservative
they lump all of that together and then
they say okay conservatives are bad this
is how the game is played the social
network said it had barred Alex Jones
the conspiracy theorist and founder of
Infowars from its platform along with a
handful of other extremists Louis
Farrakhan the outspoken black
nationalist minister who has frequently
been criticized for his anti-semitic
remarks was also been the Silicon Valley
company said these users were disallowed
from using Facebook and Instagram under
its policies against dangerous
individuals and organizations now their
statements here is is so impermissibly
vague it's so insanely vague if you're
gonna ban somebody from your platform
you should have a pretty good reason
you're talking about Facebook which is
the biggest social media platform on
planet Earth with billions of users if
you are a platform you really should
have to release a specific statement
explaining what this person did wrong
not only
the person has a right to defend
themself against the charge which could
very well be a smear but also so that
everybody else knows what the rules are
but Facebook is acting like an arbitrary
centralized government here banning
people without even we don't need to
give you an excuse why you're a banner
just banned why well because you we call
you a hateful extremist well what makes
somebody a hateful extremist Facebook
has no hard definition because it's an
innately malleable term a Facebook
spokeswoman said in a statement quote
we've always been individuals or
organizations that promote or engage in
violence and hate regardless of ideology
the process for evaluating potential
violators is extensive and it is what
led us to our decision to remove those
accounts today well thanks
I now know nothing about your standard
this statement itself has a bunch of
problems embedded in it so they say
they've always bans individuals or
organizations that promote or engage in
violence and hate
okay well Alex Jones has been promoting
exactly the same sorts of material for
years only now do you decide that he has
to be banned Malu gianopolous has been
promoting the exact same sort of stuff
for years only now do you side he has to
go loose Farrakhan has been calling Jews
termites for years only now do you
decide that he has to go so what changed
what was the new thing that happened
that changed Facebook's opinion on all
of this that's question number one
question number two they say that
they've banned individuals or
organizations that promote or engage in
violence and hate okay so how about
organizations that promote violence
against like Isis so as my friend Eric
Weinstein pointed out he suggested
correctly that he is a supporter of the
Peshmerga in Kurdistan fighting Isis
they're engaged in violence does that
mean that he is engaged in supporting
violence I mean you're gonna have to
make some distinctions here I would
assume and then they conflate violence
and hate organizations that promote or
engage in violence in hate because Alex
Jones so far as I'm aware has not
engaged in violence now if you can show
me evidence that he had but like I do
not I've seen no evidence that Paul
Joseph Watson another person who has
been mainly because he's the top
reporter at Infowars has seen no
evidence at all that Paul Joseph Watson
has engaged in violence now we have to
make a distinction between violence and
speech I'll explain in just a second
first let's talk about your sleep
quality so the fact is I am NOT a good
Slee
which means that when I go to sleep I
better have the best mattress on the
market good news I do helix sleep has a
quiz they take two minutes to complete
and matches your body type and sleep
preference to the perfect mattress for
you whether you're a side sleeper or hot
sleeper with you like a plush or a firm
bed with helix there's no more confusion
no more compromising helix sleep is
rated the number one mattress by GQ and
Wired magazine CNN called it the most
comfortable mattress they've ever slept
on just go to helix sleep calm /ban take
their two minutes sleep quiz they will
match you to a customized mattress that
will give you the best sleep of your
life for couples helix can even split
that mattress down the middle providing
individual support needs and feel
preferences for each side they've got a
10 year warranty you get to try it out
for 100 nights at risk free they'll even
pick it up for you if you don't love it
but you definitely will helix is
offering up to 125 bucks off all
mattress orders for our listeners get up
to 125 bucks off at helix sleep comm
slash Ben that's helix sleep comm slash
Ben for up to 125 dollars off your
mattress order helix sleep calm / Ben my
wife and I have a helix sleep mattress
because we took that quiz the mattress
came in the mail it's personalized for
us it is great it is so good that I got
one for my sister for her wedding go
check it out at helix sleep comm / Ben
and get 125 bucks off your mattress
order that's helix sleep comm / Ben for
the most comfortable mattress on planet
earth yulux leap comm / friend also
won't cost you an arm and a leg okay so
back to this statement from Facebook
they say again that they've always been
individuals or organizations that
promote or engage in violence and hate
so as I say the violence standard is
vague and then they're conflating
violence and hate
so people saying bad things is not the
same thing as people issuing calls for
say murder I should know this because as
news have reported there's a person who
was arrested this week for him for
making violent death threats against
Jared Kushner and Donald Trump jr. and
who has made violent death threats
against me and against my employees okay
this this person was engaged in a level
of criticism that is not the norm that's
why this person has been arrested right
now and thank you to law enforcement for
doing their job there's a vast
difference between that and people who
just say bad things about me who say
hateful things about me and there are
plenty of people who say hateful things
about me on a regular basis there is a
vast difference between people utilize
their free speech in ways that I don't
like I get hit by more of it than I was
the number-one target of an anti-semitic
pile in 2016 according to the
anti-defamation league the number one
target I never filed a police report
with any of this if I know the
difference between people who are
spewing hateful garbage at me and people
who are actively threatening my life
there's a difference between violence
and and hate there's a difference
between speech and violence no matter
how much I dislike the speech so that's
a distinction that Facebook seems to be
obliterating and then finally they have
no hard definition as to what is hateful
so this is completely arbitrary
now it's okay well basically what it
feels like is that Facebook came up with
a list of people that they wanted to ban
who were anti left I don't want to say
they're on the right because again I
think that the right is a somewhat
confusing term sometimes when I say the
right generally I'm talking about
conservatives when the press uses the
right they mean people who are anti left
I don't think that those are the same
category of people there are a lot of
people who are anti left who also
happened to be not conservative and anti
conservative one group of people who
seem to be anti left but also are not
conservative in any way our white
supremacist for example there are anti
left because they don't like
multiculturalism and because they they
are racial supremacists and all of that
but they are not conservative because
they don't believe in limited government
they don't believe in the values of
Western civilization they scorn
judeo-christian values they scorn the
idea of freedoms in the Constitution but
those are people who are anti left but
they are not conservative the media will
consider them right so for purposes of
the media's terminology the people who
they are banning many of them are on the
quote-unquote right they really mean
anti left okay but they've kind of
through Lewis Farrakhan in there so that
they could say listen we're not biased
here we're throwing in Louis Farrakhan
too but the fact is that again none of
these people said anything new that got
the man Facebook is simply deciding that
they want to oust people that they
consider hateful now I may even agree
with some of the people who they
consider hateful again I've been
personally targeted by several of the
people on this list but that does not
mean that my definition of hate is the
definition of hate that is legally
applicable it doesn't mean that my
definition of hate should trump
everybody else's definition of hate
there really is too much play in the
joints here now I think that a Facebook
wanted to
issue rules that say you're not allowed
to call people certain names for example
like you can't call somebody the n-word
like how about a clear definition of
rules how about that that's pretty much
all that people are asking for and
Facebook refuses to grant that instead
they wish to go after people along vague
standards and those standards do not
apply equally to everybody I'll show you
in just one second okay so facebook
suggests that they have this constant
standard they say that the process for
evaluating potential violators is
extensive it's what led us to our
decision to remove these accounts today
Facebook's move says the New York Times
is one of the tech industry's broadest
actions to punish high-profile
extremists at a time when social media
companies are under fire for allowing
hateful content and misinformation to
spread on their services it's a
politically delicate moment they say and
then the only suggestion that we have
seen thus far with regard to why many of
these people were banned is because many
of these people featured shows hosting
for example Gavin McGinnis so Facebook
found instances of extremism by Alex
Jones and others that push the company
to take action against them according to
the New York Times for example Jones
last year hosted an info war show
featuring Gavin McGinnis a far-right
political commentator whom Facebook had
designated as a he'd figure okay you
know who used to host Gavin McGinnis was
see our TVs see our TV used to have a
show with Gavin McGinnis now the blaze
TV are they gonna be on the blaze TV
Gavin McGinnis has appeared on a wide
variety of shows including Fox News does
this mean Fox News will now be banned
yay innopolis had signaled praise for
Gavin McGinnis earlier this year by the
way on the sunny on the spectrum of
people who suck Gavin McInnes is
actually not as crappy as is mildly
innopolis
in my personal opinion but if the idea
is anybody who's ever talk to Gavin
McGinnis gets thrown out well then this
is going to create quite a problem for
Facebook as well now the reason it's
gonna create quite a problem for
Facebook and for Instagram for example
is because one of the people they banned
was Louis Farrakhan Louis Farrakhan is
as evil in his views as anybody on the
list I would say more evil in his views
then pretty much everyone on the list
he's probably the most evil of the
people who are on this list Louis
Farrakhan for years he's been an open
brutal blatant anti-semite who uses
genocide a language about Jews and Louis
Farrakhan is being
pushed today by Snoop Dogg so his
Instagram and Facebook are they gonna
put everything in a band Snoop Dogg
because the fact is that according to
the New York Times people like Alex
Jones are being banned not for stuff
that they did but for featuring Gavin
McGinnis and Miley Annapolis is being
banned by the way I think maillot sucks
right Milo is the kind of person as a
human being who during the 2016 election
he said that I was insufficiently
committed to the cause of preserving
whiteness in the United States
effectively and he called me a cook for
this and on the day that my son was born
he sent me a picture of a black baby on
Twitter because obviously I wanted my
wife to have sex with a black man to
produce a black child because I was in
favor of what the racial mixing of the
United States or something I mean it's
just it was an insane thing so Gavin so
so yeah Annapolis is bad on his on his
own merit but you Annapolis is being
banned because he signaled praise for
Gavin McGinnis okay fine if that's the
standard why is Snoop Dogg's so on
Facebook and Instagram yesterday he put
out an Instagram video in which he
actively encouraged people to post
videos of Louis Farrakhan on Facebook
and on Instagram this is okay Snoop Dogg
was at the White House by the way with
Barack Obama Snoop Dogg is a deeply
influential public figure so does Snoop
Dog go away because if it's guilt by
association that's a pretty strong
association is it not
if you down would it like I'm down with
it post your favorite Minister Farrakhan
video on your Instagram and Facebook
page show some love to a real brother
post it right now
he got footage everywhere if you ain't
got none snatched it off of YouTube it's
everywhere put up some Minister Louis
Farrakhan footage show some love show
what he really be talking about
educating truth came ban all of us can't
ban all of us he's a real brother okay
so there is Snoop Dogg not just making
the case for free speech for bliss
Farrakhan but defending was Farrakhan
he's a real brother show what he really
be talking about okay that okay so
you're telling me that Milo is banned or
Paul Joseph Watson is banned for so let
me just get this straight Paul Joseph
Watson is banned because he is
associated with Alex Jones who was
associated with Gavin McGinnis is this
the standard Facebook is using now okay
you're gonna have to ban Snoop Dogg
right Snoop Dogg is
actively associating with Louis
Farrakhan if this is the standard now I
don't think any of these people should
be banned and I think that if they are
banned I need a clear standard as to why
these people should be banned Facebook
won't even articulate dad I love this
jodan Donovan the director of Harvard's
Technology and social change research
project who studies online extremism
says I'm sure they're gonna make a
slippery slope argument here no I'm not
making a slippery slope argument I am
making an argument that you do not have
clear standards by any stretch of the
imagination I'm not saying you're going
after Alex Jones therefore you'll go
after Paul Joseph Watson therefore you
will go after me that is not the case
that I am making the case I am making is
that you have not articulated any
standard at all and so you have having
not articulated a standard it's not that
I suspect there will be a slippery slope
I am suggesting there is no absolute
principle that is being applied here and
I have proof I have proof that there is
no absolute principle being applied here
this proof comes courtesy of Jewish
insider today quote in a letter Facebook
vice-president Joel Kaplan makes clear
the site will not remove lies or content
that is inaccurate and that includes
denying the Holocaust so if you are an
open Holocaust denier you will not be
removed from Facebook but if you once
had a conversation with Gavin McGinnis
or said something nice about Gavin
McGuinness not on Facebook you will be
removed from Facebook Kaplan who's the
vice president for global public policy
at Facebook he said that Facebook
intends to allow Holocaust denial on the
platform so long as it doesn't advocate
violence against Jewish people in any
way by the way this is the actual
correct perspective what Kaplan is
articulating here should be the
perspective you should be allowed to say
whatever you want on places like
Facebook so long as you're not
advocating for violence because there's
a stark difference between violence and
speech that is unpalatable and gross and
terrible Kaplan says I want to
underscore that Facebook rejects hate we
take down any Content that celebrates
defends or attempts to justify the
Holocaust so let me let me get this
straight if you deny the Holocaust if
you say it didn't happen you're cool but
if you take down but if you put up
content that says the Holocaust was
justified then you're bad what does he
think Holocaust deniers do does he think
that Holocaust deniers are just like no
you know I just I have questions about
the historicity is that really what he
thinks that Holocaust denial is
Holocaust denial is a way of downplaying
the evil of the Nazis
what Holocaust denial is for is the same
goes for any Content that mocks
Holocaust victims accuses victims of
lying about atrocities spews hate or
advocates for violence against Jewish
people in any way so now he's broadening
the standard again but the standard is
so inconsistent that like my sister has
been targeted on Facebook by anti-semite
she's reported them for years
okay nothing has ever happened to any of
these people this is this is a wildly
inconsistent standard and the media who
are celebrating Facebook for doing this
out there finally standing up to hate I
have some questions about this media I
have some questions about these free
speech firefighting advocates because I
don't think that that's actually what
they are doing here I don't think that's
actually what they are doing here and
and again if we are going to now start
banning people for having guests on
their program you know who had Alex
Jones on his program Joe Rogan so it's
YouTube and Facebook are these people
gonna ban Joe Rogan now and then because
I had Joe Rogan on are they gonna be on
me and then because they had me on are
they gonna ban everyone has it been done
pretty much like I've been on with Vox
yeah this is all nonsense it's anti-free
speech nonsense I'll talk about the
legality of it in a second because there
are people calling for regulation of
Facebook I'll talk about what that would
look like whether that should be done in
a second but first I want to talk about
what the media are doing here and while
I don't trust the media to set a
standard for hate and a standard for for
what should be ban first you guys heard
me talk about frame birds before you
know they make it super easy and
affordable to custom frame your favorite
things from print and posters to the
photos on your phone Mother's Day is
around the corner that perfect gift for
mom it's already on your phone right now
it only takes a few minutes to order
just upload your photo and order by
Sunday May 5th forget indeed free
delivery in time for Mother's Day just
go to frame bridge calm and upload your
photo or they'll send you packaging to
safely mail in your physical pieces
preview that item online in any frame
style choose your favorite or get free
recommendations from their talented
designers the expert team at frame
bridge will custom frame your item
deliver your finished piece directly to
you or they can deliver to mom in time
for Mother's Day when you place your
order by Sunday May 5th instead of the
hundreds you would pay at a traditional
framing store their prices start at 39
bucks all shipping is free I've spent
hundreds of dollars in the past on
framing no reason for you to do the same
and get better frames from frame range
for cheaper plus my listeners will get
15% off their first order at frame
bridge comm when they use my code
Shapiro order a custom gift for any mom
in your life in minutes go to frame
bridge comm use promo code Shapiro
you'll save an additional 15% off your
first order just go to frame bridge comm
promo code Shapiro frame bridge comm
promo code Shapiro go check it out right
now so members of the media who suggest
that they they and they alone have a
window into the meaning of hate I mean I
saw members of the media celebrating
this yesterday because they don't like
any of the figures on the list guess
what I'm not fond of any of the figures
on the list and I've been targeted
personally by many of them I keep
repeating that because I do not have a
stake in these people staying online
other than that I like free speech which
seems like a pretty heavy stake hey the
reason I don't trust the media on this
stuff is to the media lie and then they
conflate to the media as I mentioned
earlier as they labeled Lewis Farrakhan
a far-right extremist there is no such
thing as a far left extremist and
everyone on the right is an extremist
who ought to be ban as evidence I point
to the pointer Institute a journalism
nonprofit organization they put up a
list of 515 news websites it identified
as unreliable they raised eyebrows this
week would have posted that index of
what it identified as unreliable news
sites the index came from verge merging
various lists identifying websites
purportedly spreading misinformation the
list was compiled by the group's
international fact-checking network it
initially included the Washington
Examiner the language on the web site
called for full boycotts by advertisers
of all of these blacklisted sites and
listen cluded everyone included daily
wire it included Drudge Report
it included Breitbart it included daily
signal from Heritage Foundation and
included the Washington Examiner
included just an enormous enormous list
of pretty much every site that was to
the right of center like all of them
were considered unreliable by pointer
and finally after blowback and they're
calling for boycotts of these folks
right this is this is what the left will
do this is why Media Matters does this
they try to label the Southern Poverty
Law Center it's all the same they tried
to generate the idea that if you are
anywhere to the right of center or anti
left in any way that you ought to be
banned that you are unreliable and that
you ought to be shut down you ought to
be
platform is the way that they put it and
pointer actually had to pull the list
but I promise you have pointer had not
pulled the list it would be decided by
the New York Times in the Washington
Post every time they mentioned The Daily
wire in any of their stories they would
say an organization that pointer has
declared unreliable they do that with
Media Matters all the time for years
they were using the Southern Poverty Law
Center a hack left organization to smear
all right wing sources every time they
mentioned Prager you or Daily wire or
anybody else they would say an
organization deemed hateful by the
Southern Poverty Law Center so the media
create this echo chamber where everybody
who disagrees with them is evil and
everybody who agrees with them is good
and you can tell who's evil and who's
good by who disagrees with you very
convenient well on Thursday night points
are actually had to pull the list their
managing editor Barbara Allen posted a
letter to the editor explaining the
decision Allen wrote that the initial
aim of the project was to provide a
useful tool for readers to gauge the
legitimacy of the information they were
consuming
however she wrote soon after we
published we received complaints from
those on the list and readers who
objected to the inclusion of certain
sites and the exclusion of others we
began an audit to test the accuracy and
veracity of the list and while we feel
that many of the sites did have a track
record of publishing unreliable
information our review found weaknesses
in the methodology we detected
inconsistencies between the findings of
the original databases that were the
sources for the list and her own
rendering of the final report as a
result she wrote that pointer was
removing this unreliable sites list
until we are able to provide our
audience a more consistent consistent
and rigorous set of criteria well there
is no consistent and rigorous set of
criteria here one of the things that I
always find amusing is that they put
together these lists the left's members
on the left do in which they say that
sites are unreliable how do they
determine unreliable they find a couple
of stories that have been wrong over the
course of a four year history and then
they say the site is unreliable you see
this in a lot of these studies ok well
the New York Times blows stories on a
pretty routine basis so to CNN these are
not considered unreliable sources
because the vast majority of stories
that they prints are not factually
inaccurate we here at the Daily wire
post 50 stories a day we've been doing
so for 4 years that means that at this
point we have posted tens of thousands
of stories it should not be hard to find
four or five stories that are unreliable
but that is also true for all these
other outlets
what this really comes down to is a
subjective method of measuring these
sites you don't like and then finding
some sort of covering excuse to ban them
it's almost impossible not to read this
stuff in this way so what should be done
about this so there's been a lot of talk
about the idea of regulating Facebook as
a public utility now I don't think that
Facebook is a public utility it's a
private company Facebook is actually
begging of the United States government
to regulate them Facebook Twitter
they've been asking members of the
government to regulate them why because
they are on the verge of being
bankrupted by the European standards on
hate speech so they're caught between
sort of a rock and a hard place in
Europe they don't have the same
standards on speech because Europe does
not respect free speech in the same way
that the United States does one of the
reasons the u.s. is better than Europe
the US has better standards on free
speech that is a very very good thing
and you are the beneficiary of it but
what's happening in Europe right now is
that the Europeans have set these
standards for hate speech and then they
are looking at suing or taking down
facebook over quote-unquote hate speech
appearing on the platform so Facebook is
now looking for similar regulation from
the United States so that they don't
have to be eaten alive by the market in
the United States they can blame it on
the government of the United States
that's what's actually happening here
now there's been a lot of talk about
whether they should be regulated because
they're effectively a monopoly I don't
think they're effectively a monopoly
because I think that there can be
competitors to Facebook I'm not a fan of
antitrust law as a general area of law
the only monopolies that I really see
our our government guaranteed monopolies
if you are just a company that is very
successful in your space and you are not
getting the customer I don't think that
you have a technical monopoly they said
intend to be a consumer side advocate
when it comes to deciding whether a
company's a monopoly there's sort of two
theories of monopoly one is that if you
are the only company in your space so
the supply side then you are monopoly
the consumer side says well who cares if
you're the only company in your space so
long as we're not galge ng the consumer
if the consumer is getting a better
product that is the purpose of the
market it is the possibility of
competition that allows for cheap
products to continue being in the
marketplace two different theories of
monopoly I tend to side with the second
theory which is why I was not in favor
of for example breaking up Microsoft in
the late 90s ok the other way of looking
at Facebook is to try and
try and ration out red to reason out
whether they are in fact a platformer or
publisher you've heard me talk about
this before in a second I'm gonna
explain legally speaking what that means
first first for decades credit cards
have been telling us to buy it now and
pay for it later with interest that's
how they make their money despite your
best intentions that interest can get
out of control really really quickly
with Lending Club you can consolidate
your debt or pay off credit cards with
one fixed monthly payment since 2007
Lending Club has helped millions of
people regain control of their finances
with affordable fixed-rate personal
loans no trips to a bank no high
interest credit cards just go to Lending
Club com tell them about yourself and
how much you want to borrow pick the
terms that are right for you if you're
approved your loan is automatically
deposited into your bank account in as
little as a few days Lending Club is the
number one peer-to-peer lending platform
with over 35 billion dollars in loans
issued go to Lending Club comm slash pen
check your rate in minutes borrow up to
40 grand
that's Lending Club comm slash been
Lending Club comm slash been all loans
made by web bank member FDIC Equal
Housing lender with your responsible
adult you should be looking to
consolidate your debt and make your life
easier you shouldn't be paying 20% on
those credit cards each and every day
instead look to borrow up to $40,000
from Lending Club com slash Ben that's
Lending Club dot-com / Ben go check them
out right now and make your finances
simpler and easier and cheaper frankly
alright in a second we're gonna get to
the legal status of Facebook first
you're gonna have to go and subscribe
$9.99 a month get to a subscription to
daily we're calm one of the reasons we
want you to subscribe folks is because
it does protect us and it protects you
from being d platformed meaning that if
in the future YouTube or Facebook decide
that they want to crack down on everyone
right-of-center well then you still get
the show it's one of the things that
allows us to keep bringing you the show
is the fact that we have subscribers so
please help us out if you get the if you
get the $99 a year version which is
cheaper than the monthly then you also
get the leftist tears tumblr leftist
Church tumblr is a magnificent piece of
vessel where it is just terrific it is
so great that people have been taking
pictures of themselves with it and
posting it online in fact it is time is
Friday to give a shout out to one of our
daily water subscribers today at Carey
sue Davis on Twitter and your daughter
Jessica thank you for supporting what we
do I take it seeing that Jessica is
wearing a Harvard Law shirt that she is
either a student or
alumnus I'm sure her left his tears
tumblr was working overtime on campus as
it always does Thank You Kari sue and
Jessica for your support I definitely
appreciate it we appreciate it here at
daily wear also when you subscribe get
all sorts of awesome stuff like for
example this week we have a Sunday
special for you oh boy we have a Sunday
special for you joining us on the Sunday
special which you will get early on
Saturday is former US ambassador to the
United Nations my spirit animal nikki
Haley and then Ryan's called that Friday
and he said ok don't say anything just
listen US ambassador to the United
Nations
I said lions I don't even know what the
United Nations does I just know
everybody hates it
[Music]
it depends has to keppa so with some
fantastic insights so click Subscribe
get that tumblr get all of our shows get
early access to the Sunday special you
will indeed thank me later go check that
out also continue to follow us at
YouTube or iTunes if you're not
subscribing please do if you haven't
left a review please do and tell all
your friends about it we are the second
most downloaded podcast in America make
us number one I mean come on let's make
this thing happen guys we are the
largest fastest growing conservative
podcast and radio show in America
you
already so let's talk for a second about
whether Facebook is a platform or a
publisher so to illustrate the
difference between a platform and a
publisher think about the difference
between your phone line and daily wire
com all right the website that I run so
your phone line if you are talking on
your phone line and you say something
terrible AT&T Verizon they are not
responsible for what happens on your
phone line none of them are responsible
for what mint mobile they're not
responsible for what happens on your
phone line because it's an open platform
okay my publisher if I print something
that is libelous we can be sued if we
violate copyright we can be sued and now
there's a section 47 USC 230 which is a
provision of the Communications Decency
Act which creates an enormous amount of
freedom on the internet it's very good
provision as a general rule section 230
was designed to protect providers or to
protect publishers effectively well
platforms effectively section 230 says
quote no provider or user of an
interactive computer service shall be
treated as the publisher or speaker of
any information provided by another
information content provider so in other
words YouTube is not really responsible
for you posting a copyright violative
video you are responsible for that
now YouTube will take it down because
they don't want to be legally liable but
they will but it is you who are
responsible for that the same thing is
true on Facebook if you decide to post
something that is a violent threat
Facebook is not responsible for your
violence right you are responsible for
your violent threat which is appropriate
these are open platforms anyone can post
virtually anything and in fact it is
even true then on Daily wire the site
that I run we are not responsible for
your comments if we have open threads
and you post something that is terrible
or libelous we are not responsible for
all that now that changes all of that
should change logically speaking if
there is no clearly articulated standard
by which comments are being removed or
by which videos are being removed in
other words let's say that YouTube
decides that they are only going to
release videos provided by users that
are that are on one topic and then they
just decide that they are going to
remove all of their topics that's a
clear standard but now let's say that
YouTube is doing what people suspect
they are doing which is D monetizing
specific sides of the aisle that they
are taking down videos that violate
certain things and not taking down other
videos
say that Facebook decides to do that the
question now is do they look more like
how I run my website daily wire where
all of my independent contractors right
for me were responsible for them
does it look more like that and we have
free contributors by the way and we are
responsible for their writing if people
write for us doesn't matter if we pay
them if we print something and it goes
through the editorial process and then
it goes up we are responsible for that
does Facebook look more like that or
does Facebook look more like an open
forum where they're like back policing
things on a on a consistent basis if
there are no standards articulated
there's a good case to be made that
section 230 of the Communications Act
should actually the Communications
Decency Act should be changed to require
that if you are a platform you should
have to have at least a clearly
articulated standard for what is removed
and what is not because otherwise you're
really not acting like a platform really
you're acting more like a publisher like
I decide on an editorial level what we
wish to publish well Facebook if they
have decided that politically motivated
concerns are the issue well then they
look more like us so that is what is
going on with these sort of vague hate
standards if you have a vague hate
standard that is only being applied to
one side of the aisle that would suggest
that you are acting more like a more
like a publisher than like a platform
and that means that there should be some
serious considerations revising section
230 of the Communications Decency Act
now the case against that just to give
the other side is that you don't want
government getting involved with
regulating websites generally you don't
want the government involved only thats
what would be happening here i think
that instead what would be happening
here is that you are opening up to
liability websites that acts like
publishers they're not quashing my free
speech I'm the publisher of Daily wire
they're not quashing my free speech the
fact that we can be sued for libel or
for copyright violation well the same
case could be made with regard to
Facebook if you're responsible for your
material you're responsible for your
material there is a better thing that
could happen here okay if Facebook is
asking for wider regulation than that by
the way they want the government to
actually regulate the speech that can be
put on Facebook but there's a better
stance than this which is how about a
clearly articulated standard that says
what you can put up and what you cannot
put up on Facebook how about that how
about like Terms of Service that aren't
impermissibly vague how about you have
to offer an excuse when you ban some
from your service and so we can all see
it and learn from the case study but
these social media companies don't want
to do that and that's why people are so
suspicious of what exactly is going on
here and they should be suspicious of
what is going on here again if you are
if you are a person who has one set a
nice thing about Paul Joseph Watson and
you're gonna be banned or if you're Paul
Jones for watching yourself right Paul
Joseph watching by the way is not nearly
as extreme just as a human from what I
have seen he's not nearly as extreme as
even Alex Jones a guy for whom he worked
but if if Paul Joseph Watson if the idea
is that Paul Joseph Watson was nice to
Gavin McGinnis myogi innopolis was nice
to Gavin McGinnis and they can be bad
again you're gonna have to ask why is
Snoop Dogg still there
why are half the people in Congress who
took pictures with Louis Farrakhan still
there these standards are not being
evenly applied because they can't even
be articulated they are not even trying
to articulate them frankly because they
know that they're gonna get help from
the mainstream media that agrees with
them that's the bottom line in the end
the New York Times very happy a free
speech newspaper supposedly is very
happy that these social media outlets
are throwing people off that they don't
like I don't like a lot of these people
either that doesn't mean that they
should be thrown off the platforms it
doesn't if you don't like what they have
to say I have an easy solution you don't
have to watch them I have another easy
solution you can yell at them all of
these are appropriate I don't mean like
physically yell at them and disturb
events I mean like you can go online and
you can yell at them I know I get a lot
of it so there's that okay meanwhile the
Democrats continue to proclaim that the
Attorney General of the United States
William bar is a liar a brutal terrible
evil liar so Nancy Pelosi says that
William bar lied what what did he lie
about she still cannot name a single lie
that William bar has told the Attorney
General of the United States has fallen
under fire for no apparent reason
he wrote a four-page synopsis of the
findings of the malla report then within
six weeks he released the entirety of
the Mullen report that's called
transparency folks that ain't a cover-up
nonetheless Democrats are going after
William bar because they wish they wish
that Robert Muller had recommended
prosecution he did not and thus
Democrats say it was William bar ruling
bar was was what stood between President
Trump and prosecution as I say if Muller
wanted to recommend prosecution he could
have instead he abdicated he handed it
over to William bar William bar
said no appropriately I've read the
report but according to Nancy Pelosi
this makes William Barr a political hack
and an emissary of evil and a liar now
she believes that he's a perjurer she
can impeach him any time I don't see her
making any serious moves in that
direction to you today I really lost
sleep last night after watching over and
over again the testimony of the Attorney
General of the United States how sad it
is how fat it is for us to see the top
law enforcement officer in our country
misrepresenting withholding the truth
from the Congress of the United States
the Attorney General of the United
States of America was not telling the
truth to the Congress of the United
States that's a crime okay well she's
gonna have to explain where the crime is
I think that the democratic definition
of crime is basically crap I don't like
well that ain't a crime lady in a second
we'll get you more on the Democrats
attacking will William bar okay so it's
not just Speaker of the House Nancy
Pelosi
who is openly suggesting without any
evidence at all that William bar
committed perjury which he did not
it is also ted Lieu who is just a
terrible congress person suggesting that
William bar the Attorney General is one
of the most dangerous men in the country
really you mean that dorky lawyer is one
for giving you a report that's sitting
in front of you you dolt my goodness
here his ears ted Lieu making that case
Attorney General Bill Barr is not one of
the most dangerous men in Washington DC
for three reasons first he intentionally
mischaracterized the Mulla report he was
then told by Rob Imola that he
mischaracterize Imola report and instead
of apologizing he doubles down and
continues to mislead the American people
second today he ignored the will of
Congress oversight responsibilities of
Congress and lawfully issued subpoenas
and third right now he is suing to
eliminate your health care coverage
let's not forget right now he is suing
in court to eliminate pre-existing
conditions health care this is just such
nonsense now here's the reality
Democrats are not gonna do anything
about William bar this is all sound and
fury signifying nothing this is them
whining and whining and bitching and
moaning because they didn't get what
they wanted from Robert Muller and they
can't blame Robert Muller because they
spent several years bill
him up as the deus ex machina who's
going to save us all from president
trump representative Hakeem Jeffries of
New York let the cat out of the bag he
said yeah we're not jailing bar so like
all this talk about how we're gonna hold
them in contempt and then throw them in
jail yeah that's not happening how do
you get this thing moving to your post
fines do you suggest maybe even as some
of said jail time for the Attorney
General of the United States well jail
time is not something that I believe is
being seriously contemplated and look
we're going to continue along the track
of trying to find common ground on
behalf of the issues that would improve
the lives of everyday Americans while at
the same time understanding that there's
another lane which is going to require
for Congress to hold the administration
accountable when it steps over the line
and we're not going to shirk that
responsibility either okay well you know
they're not gonna short out responsible
except that there is no responsibility
here because they're not gonna do
anything they're not interested in doing
anything so and all of this is
manufactured meanwhile the House
Judiciary Committee is trying to get
robert muller there in the wild hope
that robert muller will come in and then
say listen I decided that I couldn't
indict because the president's the
president but secretly you guys should
impeach him that's what they want from
Robert Miller I don't think Robert
Miller is gonna give that to them
apparently NBC News and ABC News are
reporting that the committee is now
speaking with Muller's team when it was
previously dealing with the Justice
Department NBC reports that a hearing
has not been finalized to date was not
set but they're apparently negotiating
with more to come testify well I mean
the network's I'm sure will be happy
with the ratings because that's exciting
stuff but we have we have Muller's
thoughts in 450 pages got things longer
than its whole story novel we have all
of his thoughts didn't hide them they
haven't been they haven't been hidden
from you they are publicly available you
can buy a print copy online right now at
Amazon this is all this is all silly
talk now the reason I think that
Democrats are truly upset about a lot of
this stuff is because there there are
new stories that are coming out pretty
much every day now
about the lengths to which the Hillary
Clinton campaign was interfering with
other countries in the election of 2016
the extent to which the intelligence
community was intervening with regard to
election 2016 there's a story that I've
mentioned over the last couple days
from the New York Times in which the New
York Times reports that the FBI sent yet
another quote-unquote spy another
investigator posing as an assistant to
meet with George papadopolis according
to the New York Times there is a woman
who posed as a as in a government
invested as a research assistant
she was actually a government
investigator she went to spy on George
papadopolis she said her name was Asura
Turk and this is this would be a spy
being deployed to go talk with a member
of the Trump campaign Trump was never
told about any of this
there will be investigations into the
extent to which the intelligence
community targeted members of the Trump
campaign whether Trump himself should
have been told and whether there was
enough of a supportive evidentiary basis
to suggest the use of informants and
surveillance against people like Carter
Page and George papadopolis okay that
Inspector General report is set to come
out I believe in June I think Democrats
are fearful of that I think Democrats
are also fearful of new reports like
this one that is coming out
according to Fox News Ukraine's embassy
wrote that a Democratic National
Committee insider reached out in 2016
seeking dirt on president Trump's team
according to a bombshell new report on
Thursday that fueled Republican that
further fueled Republican allegations
that Democrats were the ones improperly
colluding with foreign agents during the
campaign ambassador Valery Tralee said
DNC contractor Alexandre chalupa pushed
for Ukraine's then president Petro
poroshenko to mention Paul Manafort
ties to Ukraine publicly during a visit
to the United States and sought detailed
financial information on his dealings in
the country according to the hill at the
time manna fort was Trump's embassy it
was Trump's campaign chairman Jay Lee
said in a statement quote the embassy
got to know miss chalupa because of her
engagement with Ukrainian and other
diasporas in Washington DC and not in
her DNC capacity we learned about her
DNC involvement later we were surprised
to see Alexander's interest in powell
from paula manna for its case it was her
own cause the embassy representatives
unambiguously refused to get involved in
any way as we were convinced that this
is a strictly u.s. domestic matter in
other words it looks like a DNC
contractor slash operative was trying to
get information for the 2016 campaign on
Paul Manafort now again that's not
collusion it wasn't collusion when Trump
jr. was talking with a Russian lawyer
about getting turned on Hillary Clinton
collusion is a quid pro quo or the
organisation of the release of
material but with that said is that just
as bad as the Trump Tower meeting I mean
yeah kinda right I mean it is trying to
get information from a foreign source
about a domestic political adversary so
Democrats are in for a rough ride here I
think and I think that they know it so
that is probably why they are attempting
to misdirect to William Barr I don't
think the next couple of months go real
well on the intelligence community I
don't think that they do a lot of
wonders for the credibility of the
Democratic Party and the intelligence
community on any of this stuff so that
may be why they are trying to misdirect
you William bar or robert muller and all
the rest of this stuff okay time for a
little bit of mailbag because it is
indeed a Friday so we begin with Leia
Leia says hey Ben a few friends and I
are planning a month-long trip for
October and at the end of our trip we
were planning to visit Turkey and
Lebanon I've traveled all over the world
with the exception to the Middle East so
when they said they wanted to visit I
said I'd be onboard however I heard you
can send her Lebanon if you've been
traveling to Israel marked on your
passport well I've never been there I
was curious of the reason for this and
what your thoughts are on traveling
there and Turkey when I'm a strong
supporter of Israel thanks and love the
show so I am not sure what the actual
rules are in Lebanon I know that those
rules do apply in places like Saudi
Arabia there are certain countries that
refuse to acknowledge the existence of
the State of Israel don't worry it's not
anti-semitism to fail to acknowledge a
Jewish state that exists it is merely a
form of anti Zionist not anti-semitism
at all those rules obviously are
targeted toward Jews that is the goal of
them Israel does not have similar rules
with any country on planet earth it's
pretty amazing that that all of that is
tolerated but it's soft bigotry of low
expectations when it comes to radical
Muslim leadership in that part of the
world Kyle says what is your arguments
people that say the economy will crash
after Trump because of his Reaganomics
type policies tax cuts trade regulations
etc is this a possibility in your mind
well number one there are very few
economists who have been consistent in
being able to predict economic crashes
this is just a reality of the situation
I think people suspect there will be one
in the sometime near future simply
because every eight to ten years in the
United States there is some sort of
economic downturn the last one was in
2008 is now 2019 so that means that will
probably do but that's more of like in
the earthquake should come in feeling
that you get sitting on the porch right
that is not based on
economic criteria I have no idea why you
would say that Reaganomics type policies
create recessions when Reaganomics type
policies created the greatest peacetime
expansion in the history of the United
States the greatest peacetime economic
States even short-term downturns like
like Black Monday back in October of was
in 1987 even that was quickly rectified
in the economy kept on growing even the
short-term downturn in 1991 was reversed
by the end of 1991 by the time 1992
election came about the economy was
already moving forward again so the idea
that Reaganomics type policies is what
quash is economic growth no one quashes
economic growth downturns are
unpredictable economic growth however is
predictably tied to a business climate
that is friendly toward business as
opposed to a heavy regulatory and tax
based climate it tends to quash growth
so we found out from Barack Obama Keith
says dear Ben I'd like to be a better
influence in defending and spreading
conservative ideas how can an average
conservative such as myself help change
hearts and minds in my daily life well a
couple of things number one you have to
read and read and read you really do
need to know the issues about what you
speak
second of all seek commonality and
common definition before you start a
conversation the way to have a bad
political conversation is for somebody
to say something like you're mean you're
cruel and then you say no I'm not
meaning cruel that's not a conversation
that's an argument what you have to do
is say I need you to define meanness and
cruelty so that we can have a definition
of what exactly we are talking about
because I don't believe your definition
if your definition is you just don't
like me well you know then we can't have
a conversation if you want to have a
conversation we have to get to common
out a commonality of terms it's funny I
have conversations with folks all the
time on a variety of issues particularly
on the other side of the aisle and to
use an example I just didn't I didn't
interview with I believe it was salon I
think and the and the reporter over at
salon was extremely it was extremely
antagonistic the the entire interview
was basically this person trying to make
an argument over it was not an interview
it was an argument and you can read the
transcript of it they wouldn't release
the audio because it made the reporter
look pretty bad that is my opinion we
asked for the release of the audio they
would not do it and then I had a similar
conversation about my book with Sean
ihling at Vox who happens to be an
honest reporter who's read my book and
who disagrees with my book
but because we were having a
conversation that was productive he
would ask my opinion on something I
would ask him for a clarification of
definition I would respond he would ask
for a clarification of my definitions he
would respond this is what is called a
nice conversation you can do that
specifics help conversations move
forward this is true in marriage it's
true in child-rearing it's true in
parenting it's true in all areas of life
specificity and clarity is what you
should be seeking in conversation if you
wish to have a conversation broad-based
terminology about which there is no
common understanding that's how you have
an argument Sara says Ben what books do
you recommend to learn more about the
israeli-palestinian conflict well
there's a great book that I've
recommended on the show by David brog
called reclaiming Israel's history it's
very short it's about 200 pages and that
gives you a pretty good background on
what you need to know there's also a
book by Eli bard called myths and facts
that I always recommend mainly because
it's bite-sized it has a myth and then
it will have the fact and that's like a
page long and it answers most of your
questions about it I'd start with those
two books and then if you want sort of
longer forum histories there's a book by
Howard sacker about it called the
history of Zionism that is that is worth
reading Benjamin Netanyahu actually
wrote a great book called a durable
peace back in the 1990s that talks about
the kind of long-term history of Israel
and the Palestinians and more than
Israel and Palestinians Israel and the
Arab world around it because the
Palestinians as a cohesive entity really
did not exist as a cohesive entity until
the creation of the State of Israel all
the Palestinians Palestinian actually
referred to Jew write the Palestine Post
was referring to the Jerusalem Post was
referring to Jews Palestinians as a
specific political entity were not
created really until 1948 and everybody
was considered Syria they not say that
they weren't indigenous to the area
there were Palestinians indigenous to
the area but they considered themselves
Syrian or Egyptian or Jordanian or Saudi
so it is worth reading all of those
books and give you more if you're
interested Anthony says hey Ben is there
ever an argument from a conservative
side for any implementation of a
Keynesian style economic policy also do
you believe we are in the late stage
capitalist system currently the the
phrase late stage capitalist is very
irritating because there is either
capitalist or is there there is non
capitalist the idea that capitalism is
moving toward an end game where it falls
apart that is a Marxist construct that I
just don't believe Marxism suggests that
eventually history will end
with the with the seizure of the means
of production by the workers and that
has not happened historically
instead what has happened historically
is a forcible seizure of the means of
production by governments and then the
collapse of that system repeatedly
because that system sucks and is
terrible for human beings so I don't
really believe in the phrase late stage
capitalist I believe in in economic that
there is such a thing as top-down
economic fascism or corporatism that
exists but I don't think that's
capitalism I think people tend to
conflate a lot of this terminology as
far as the the argument for
implementation of a Keynesian style
economic policy which I assume would
mean seizure of money from people who
are more wealthy giving it to people who
are poor so they can start the the in
fact so they can start spending that
money that spending is better than
saving no I disagree with Keynesianism
there's a great book by the author of
economics in one lesson Henry Hazlitt
it's got a 450 page book that that
really breaks down Keynes his work at
length it's very detailed so if you're
interested in that that's available
Richard says hello mr. Shapiro I've
heard several times you say the Congress
has subpoena power where does it say
that in the Constitution is it a part of
the Necessary and Proper powers well
Congress can pass legislation that
allows them to subpoena then the other
branches have the power to resist a
subpoena and then the judiciary gets to
decide whether the subpoena in fact hold
so they have to pass a piece of
legislation you're correct there is
nothing in the Constitution of the
United States that specifically refers
to subpoena power but there's no doubt
that Congress does have investigative
powers under the Constitution that's how
they keep the other branches in check
Michaels has been do you think there's
any Republican who if they were to run
could beat Donald Trump in the primary
maybe Jim mattis Mitt Romney or Ben
Shapiro no the answer is no I think
Donald Trump would win every primary
he's the incumbent president of the
United States there has yet to be an
incumbent President of the United States
who loses in the primaries even LBJ did
not lose in the primaries he just came
close to losing in the prime in a couple
early primaries and decided not to run
so that is that is not the same thing
the strongest primary contenders have
never taken out an incumbent president
it's never happened okay let's see
Jackson says Heyman totally agree with
your assessment of endgame thank you
thank you I appreciate it being a huge
Marvel fan I still enjoyed it totally
fair I said if you're a Marvel fan and
you're really into it and he likes it I
guess it was
twenty-one movies leading up to avengers
endgame and you're looking for the
Easter eggs and it's all nostalgia for
you and fanservice
totally fine with that I personally
thought it was bloated I thought that
what they did what the main characters
didn't make any sense
I had a lot of critiques of endgame I
listen I was just I wanted to enjoy it
the same as everybody else the things
gonna make up a jillion dollars I mean
it's already racked up I think its first
by the end of first weekend it had
racked up almost 1.5 billion dollars
worldwide I wish I could enjoy it like
everybody else I just have critiques
Jackson says I was wondering how you
would have constructed the final battle
personally I would have just had iron
man thor and Captain America fight
Thanos and his generals yes this is
correct the battle at the very end of
Avengers endgame should not have taken
place meaning that it is obvious that
the anos is facing off against them and
so as I mentioned in my review of the
ventures endgame yesterday on my show on
the podcast the biggest problem with
Avengers at endgame one of the big
problems my business partner Jeremy
boring pointed this out is that the
relative powers of the various
characters make no sense so in the first
Avengers infinity war Thanos is barely
able to hold off just Thor and he's got
the Infinity Gauntlet while he's doing
that and the Infinity Gauntlet is
SuperDuper powerful well at the end of
Avengers endgame spoilers here okay guys
you're all worn at the ends of
adventures and at the end of Avengers
endgame
Thanos does not have the gauntlet he's
just a big guy and he's a big guy and
he's holding off simultaneously Thor and
Captain America and Iron Man he's
holding all of them off and Captain
America has has Thor's hammer I mean
he's got all these things and and still
Thanos is holding them off without the
Infinity Gauntlet how how so you'd have
to construct the finals in the final
battle scene better also there's
something inherently a little bit unfair
about a 301 so the only way to make that
fair is if he does have the Infinity
Gauntlet for example also having Captain
Marvel come in and she's and she's able
to basically take on Thanos alone like
none of these relative power
arrangements make any sense why is she
so much more powerful than Thor the god
of the god of thunder why like none of
this again
the internal logic doesn't make a lot of
sense I think there was a way to
construct it where it makes sense where
for example Tony
Starck is wounded that would make sense
or Captain America is finally feeling
his age this would make sense or you or
you have or you have Thor who is so
broken that he can't fight properly
that would make something there like
there are ways to construct this but I
just don't think it was done it turned
into kind of the same big beat him up
smash them up battle you have at the end
of every one of these Marvel movies
William says hey Ben you said many times
on your show you're a huge sports fan
I'm curious what your favorite teams are
from the major sports NBA NFL and MLB so
at number one
NHL should be included in the major
sports number two I don't know III just
didn't grow up with hockey I wish I had
because every time I go to a hockey game
it's awesome so I'm a I am a Blackhawks
fan you know sort of peripherally but
NBA NFL and MLB NBA I'm a Celtics fan I
know I live in Los Angeles it makes no
sense I'm a Celtics fan because I picked
up all of my father's sports allegiances
because like religion fans I'm for
sports teams is picked up from your
parents this is why my kids will be
white sox fans even though there are two
generations removed from chicago so the
NBA I'm a Celtics fan because my parents
went to school in Boston and the Chicago
Bulls really were not a thing when my
dad was growing up so he was a Celtics
fan he was partially a Celtics fan his
Red Auerbach was the owner of it was the
owner / general manager of the Boston
Celtics and was an early integrator of
the NBA for example was Jewish etc the
NFL I'm a Chicago Bears fan so I picked
up all the Chicago allegiances I know
it's a terrible fate to be a Chicago
Bears fan and Mitsui Biscay yeah okay
and an MLB I am a huge Chicago White Sox
fan if you wish to hear my thoughts
about the Chicago White Sox all you have
to do is go to amazon.com my father and
I wrote a full book about the 2005
Chicago White Sox championship season we
traced every single game of the season
and it's a series of letters from me to
my dad and back and forth it's really a
lot of fun it's called say it so you can
go check that out at amazon.com yeah al
veal says hey man question how would you
respond to the argument regarding
abortion then the life and death
situation the life of the mother takes
precedence over the unborn baby
admitting to a certain extent that the
two lives are not the equal at that
point unborn versus born while I myself
have a bunch of issues with what is
extrapolated from this point I'm having
a hard time discrediting the logic well
the logic makes make sense that you
prefer the life of the mother so long as
the baby is not born yet because there
is a
between unborn and born with regard to
choice of life but that does not mean
that in a vacuum you can just kill the
unborn like this is what people seem to
get wrong you don't actually have to
make the argument that an embryo is of
the exact same value you don't actually
have you can make the argument you don't
have to make the argument then the
embryo is of the exact same value as a
30 year old person in order to make the
argument that an embryo must be
preserved you don't have to make that
argument because it is not a choice
hey the choice is between your
inconvenience and the embryo or your
your wishes and the embryos existence
and that that is not the same choice so
the first what people do is they create
the false choice between the existence
of an adult life and an unborn life and
then the next thing that they do is they
say that all cases are that choice which
they are not so it's just bad logic I
don't think you have to accept even the
you don't even have to accept the
premise that all life is innately of
equal value to it especially you know in
early stages you don't have to accept
you can't accept it again you can say an
embryo is exactly the same as a as a
fully grown human being but you don't
have to in order to make the argument
for the preservation of the embryo
that's historically been the Jewish
argument for example okay time for a
quick thing I like and then we'll do a
quick thing I hate and then we'll get
out of here
so things I like so yesterday was Yom
Hashoah I talked at length about
Holocaust Remembrance Day and there's a
great video I saw yesterday from L all
the Israeli national airline there the
plane which is full of Jews were going
to Israel on Yom Hashoah they were
flying over Germany and the a guy got
got on the one of the flight attendants
got on the intercom and he starts
telling everybody about how many like
his grit all of his grandparents were
slaughtered in the camps he gets on the
intercom and he says and if they could
see now that there is an airplane with a
Jewish star flying over Germany imagine
imagine the miracle of that it really is
a miraculous miraculous thing how bad
was the Holocaust the Holocaust was so
horrible in terms of human populations
that there are still fewer Jews on earth
80 years after the Holocaust and there
were before the Holocaust and so many
Jews were murdered it's an amazing
amazing thing and then all the people on
the plane start singing together and
dancing in the
it's pretty it's pretty amazing well I
was asked yesterday by somebody for
movies that concern the Holocaust I
mentioned some yesterday one of the ones
that I mentioned that has been wildly
underrated there was a movie a TV movie
that was done about the Warsaw Ghetto
Uprising which is one of the great
inspiring stories of Jewish history a
small band of barely armed Jews had been
cut off by the outside world holding up
for a month against the mechanization of
the German military forces it is it is a
strong argument by the way that people
should be armed
because armed Jews held off the Nazis
for a month in the middle of complete
privation without proper ammunition
without proper firearms there's very
good movie called uprising as I say I
believe it's only available on DVD you
can order from Amazon it's it's
certainly worth the watch it's it's
quite good in fact I find the Warsaw
Ghetto Uprising stories so important
that I'm actually working on a musical
about it with my father my father writes
musical so I brought the libretto my dad
writes the music so we're hoping to
bring that I think probably sometime
next year
in any case that ok time for a quick
thing that I hate so Burger King all
these corporations now feel the need to
social justice message I am a huge
advocate of people who have mental
illness need to seek help people who
have mental illness need to seek help
they I mental illness runs in my family
people who have a problem need to seek
help they need to find somebody who can
help them Burger King runs a commercial
about mental illness and it makes no
sense at all it just doesn't make any
sense so here is Burger King's weird
commercial which I mean I guess
capitalism for the win but here is
Burger King trying to I guess push
depression eating is that the idea here
not everybody wakes up happy sometimes
you feel sad scared crappy Elias is that
you let me feel my way to leave this is
just a bunch of little little poetic
statements about feelings and then the
chorus is I just want you to let me feel
my way you can feel your way okay but
what you really should do if you're
depressed and you're down you're having
a problem is you should go see somebody
and do something about it
Burger King's eventual solution to all
of this is that if we just let you feel
however you want to feel without trying
to intervene and we let them then we
give you a bunch of meals that you're
gonna eat so we're gonna let you harden
your arteries that's the proper solution
is for you to feed the like very weird
very weird tank very very odd take by
the way for folks who are depressed one
of the greatest methods of an trying to
fight depression is something called
cognitive behavioral therapy in which
the goal is not to let you feel your way
the goal is to try to explain to you how
you can intervene in the chain of your
own feelings and stop yourself from
feeling away you don't want to feel
burger king making money off depression
eating and then virtue signaling about
it
welcome to if there is a such a thing as
late stage capitalism this would this
would be what it look like man alright
so we will be back here later today with
two additional hours plus remember you
should subscribe see can get the Sunday
special a day early got nikki Haley this
weekend so that's pretty awesome stuff
go check we have big a bunch of big-name
guests who are coming up also we have a
very special episode that I can't wait
to tell you about of the Sunday special
coming up next month it's gonna be just
fantastic I've been doing the interviews
for it all week it's so good we'll get
to that but go subscribe so you get all
that stuff I'm Ben Shapiro this is the
Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
this is the Ben Shapiro show executive
producer Jeremy boring senior producer
Jonathan hey our supervising producer is
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stephens edited by Adam SIA
Vettes audio is mixed by Mike Carmina
hair and makeup is by Joshua alvera
production assistant NIC Sheehan the Ben
Shapiro show is a daily wire production
copyright day Lee Weyer 2019 hey guys
over on the Matt Walsh show today
Facebook has stepped up its censorship
efforts so we'll discuss the great purge
of supposedly dangerous people people
who all reside coincidentally I'm sure
on one side of the political spectrum
and what we'll also talk about the
ethical and legal implications of what
they're doing
also we're now being told that it is
white supremacists to try to be
objective objectivity is white supremacy
so I want to talk about how the left has
made white supremacy into a completely
meaningless concept we'll talk about
that and other topics today over on the
Matt Walsh show